where would you rate yourself on a scale
of one to ten ten
ten see what would you rate this girl on
a scale of one to ten
the tops four where would you rate
yourself on a scale of one to ten tops
four what would you rate this guy on a
scale of one to ten four four what would
you rate yourself on a scale of one to
ten right now I'm feeling like a ten a
ten do you think other people would
agree I hope so what would you rate this
girl on a scale of one to ten eight and
eight what would you rate yourself on a
scale of one to ten seven seven do you
think other people would agree
maybe maybe would you rate this guy on a
scale of one to ten I would rate him
well I have a boyfriend but he looks
sweet so I would rate him at my six six
all right what would you rate yourself
in a skill one time a ten a ten awesome
do you think other people would agree
um I don't know
why would you rate yourself on a scale
of one to ten
other people would agree oh of course
all right what would you reach yourself
on a scale of one to ten seven seven do
you think other people would agree 100
maybe higher what would you rate this
guy over here on a scale of one to ten
oh my God a ten I did I would say seven
and a half what would you rate yourself
underscore one to ten
I don't know probably like a six you
think others would agree would y'all
agree absolutely
friends you didn't hear what a friend
said
she said absolutely no no no don't don't
don't ask your friends
your friends are the worst people for
that my girl I'm talking to you my girls
but she said absolutely she said a six
and the girl said absolutely yeah but
you that's not good
on average that's that's that was a good
one but usually don't ask your friends
your friends will not be real with you
what would you rate yourself on this go
one to ten I don't know probably like a
six do you think others would agree
would y'all agree
[Applause]
[Laughter]
she said absolutely and her friend's
like you're not supposed to say that my
friends is immediately that is exactly
and if you go ask your friends if you go
to the comments everyone said she said
absolutely absolutely is insane oh not
the ads I would cry she said this she
said the six to get like a better grade
and the girl's like absolutely girl
you're messed up no no I think what
happened was
homegirl's drunk yes smash I think she
could have said I'm a one million she
would have went absolutely I think she
just absolutely
but girls don't ask yourself
I don't know that's exactly how you're
supposed to be I don't feel good about
myself oh my God girl stop it's so hot
and then a girl that's actually hot that
girl's got the goblin don't ask your
friends that's wow don't ask your
friends it's interesting just because
like you see how like ladies always rate
themselves and they're going like for
absurd numbers yeah and dudes always
rate themselves lower even when the
dudes gave the women a high rating the
dudes rated themselves lower yeah it's
uh I think
um socially speaking I just think like
women are heavily encouraged to uh until
you make it
for good looks I guess but yo it's like
it's not Sisterhood you know what I mean
like we gonna boost each other up yeah
but but yo it's like I can't rate myself
at 10. I've been to Carnival you
understand I've seen tens
what the girls [ __ ] drool over I've
seen what they look like they don't look
like me that's for true they're not that
they're not my height they don't look
like me yo girls try to boost me
sometimes they'd be like oh I have a
hearing aid i'm like [ __ ] I've seen
eights yo stop I've seen the lived
experiences of AIDS I don't live that
exactly my brother is extremely
attractive we've been going out of the
club sometimes I see how he gets women
and I see how much I had to struggle I'm
like we not on the same level
and it's okay you can just say you find
me attractive it's okay to say you like
a six
you say that girl you say yo Amber you a
sexy sick oh about to give you this 666
right you can do that we can find a way
to bridge that Gap I'm okay you a little
bit above average I'm a little bit above
average let's get average okay
but
you ain't got a lot fresh my man's 28
going on 80 and I don't want that to be
you guys and that's why today's sponsor
t.h Henley is coming in to save the day
I get compliments on my skin all the
time people be asking what's your
skincare routine how do you get your
skin and for a lot of fellas talking
about skin care is a little bit awkward
because either we're too ashamed to do
it or it seems a little bit too feminine
but the truth is having rough skin or
having all these little dents everywhere
isn't some that you necessarily want
especially if it's things that you can
easily avoid through very very good
products I recommend going through that
process and that's where TJ Henley comes
in they got a great system in place
where you can use their products to
achieve your skin care goals I
personally recommend that you start with
the level one system which comes with
all the basics a daily face wash which
gets rid of all the dirt and Grime on
your face then you got it two times per
week exfoliating scrub to get rid of all
the dead skin cells and an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 because we all
need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the Sun and the cool
thing about Tia Shanley is all their
boxes come with instructions in addition
to amazing skin members of th Henley get
tons of benefits like at least 20 off
retail price the ability to pause or
cancel at any time as well as free us
shipping click on the link below and
save 30 off your first purchase and also
you can get a free gift I'm just saying
if you wash your booty wash your beauty
don't wait rub out that face so you can
actually start looking fresh
occur but if you compare to the world
absolutely the world that's the truth
I've seen tens in the world yes well
girls Drew over I ain't nowhere near yes
nowhere absolutely and I'm not even
saying that to fish for compliment
that's the difference between me and
y'all I'm telling y'all I've seen what
[ __ ] like drop their panties
over yeah I ain't the one
me neither and guess what
I'm happy with what I got truth what I
got ain't much
but I like what I got I agree I like I
like this I'm good Hey listen I build
this confidence over the years it's it
ain't much but it's pretty good you
wanna know the truth
a six is better than a four
and some of you [ __ ] are forced and I
feel for y'all but as bad as you fours
are some [ __ ] are twos and some of you
[ __ ] are twos watching right now and
all the fours were like that sounds even
rougher I don't even feel bad and bad
for the twos because some of you twos
aren't as bad as the zeros and there's
some zeros out there and I feel really
bad for y'all and there's some people in
the negative yeah yeah yeah shout out to
my negatives and it's it's fine if you
think you are negative it's it's like
it's fine like stop being like Oh my god
listen listen people be people you have
the right to be average
that goes for guys and girls
you have the right to be average
it's okay don't try to be no but I think
I don't give a [ __ ] what you think
you're wrong
okay but I think in the most you're
wrong you're wrong stop okay I mean hey
man man we all got her props we all got
our problems we all got her positive I'm
like RPG character you know what I'm
saying in terms of physicality I got
like a six but you know I mean I made up
for it in Charisma in some other spots
they gave me a few extra bonus points
you they gave it to you in strength and
uh Charisma as well your charisma is
really high this is dng nerdship sure
without any point
what else do you want to say about this
talk
no I understand why wouldn't lose
themselves is because so much of their
like self-worth and Foundations based
off how they look yeah and so they have
a hard you know between the ladies they
try to encourage each other so that's
easier to manage that I get why they do
it it's just when I don't subscribe to
the numbering game that they do I get
annoyed just because like we're like oh
so whatever what would you rate me and
I'm like do you honestly want to know
you know it's hard pill for some ladies
to swallow like being told the truth and
I'm like don't ask me I remember one
girl she was writing her co-worker said
she was telling me all my co-workers are
eights and above I said [ __ ] where you
work and she said an engineering firm I
said if you don't stop [ __ ] lying
right now I look at the picture you want
to see what it looked like oh you showed
me yeah oh you're so oh you should
remember when I showed you you showed me
and I was like oh my God I don't think I
saw anybody close to a seven oh my God
no no I'm not even close to a five and
to be fair busted and to be fair to be
fair
Everybody's Got A variation meaning like
yes if you're a six there's a variation
of two that you get yes you can based
off the person who's rating use taste
you can go down to four or up to an
eight at most if you're a nine you go
down to a seven or up to a ten depending
on who's looking at you right based off
of like physical things and little
things like that and then if you open
your mind you could drop to a zero I've
seen some more you have seen pause I've
seen some gorgeous gorgeous women
insufferable you you you you you could
oh my God
oh my God that should be happening bro
but it's just crazy all the women rains
outside it's like they all refer from
the same script or like you could even
you know people do this whole fake
humble [ __ ] all the time but sometimes
you dating a woman right and she's like
so how hot do you think I have and you
say a night she's like why am I not a
10. I was like what happened to leaving
space to self-improof who's perfect out
here but hey ladies baby y'all can let
us know why do you guys need to hear
that you're a 10. is that really
necessary and is that reasonable to
expect people I don't think so two not a
10. yeah I just tell people don't answer
me because I don't want to have to tell
you the truth and if you because if you
don't want to help you can't handle it
don't ask don't I won't say it but if
you ask and you say you good I'm gonna
tell you straight up what it is I won't
lie to your face I I just I don't think
it's good for anybody okay
it would be against my my core values to
have to lie to me you know how rare a 10
is
I've seen two in my whole life you know
how rare at 10 is and they were on
Instagram so they're most most chances
are you're not a 10.
most chances yeah you have as much odds
of being a 10 as you do a zero